aux etats-unis dans ce qu'on vote aux
législatives on vaut également pour bien
d'autres choses référendum municipaux
locaux etc
un exemple les municipales de washington
avec le retour à la tête de la capitale
américaine du maire noir marianne marine
souvenez-vous celui là même qui s'était
fait prendre il y a trois ans à peine
dans une chambre d'hôtel en train de se
droguer en compagnie d'une prostituée
thierry thulliez janvier 90 une chambre
d'hôtel de washington et dans la chambre
michael berry le maire qui gît par le
fbi ya kg alors qu'il fume du crack en
compagnie de sa petite amie
l'intervention des agents du fbi iai est
musclé arrêtés puis jugés bien lui
écopera de six mois de prison
quatre ans plus tard le même homme
désintoxiquer réélu à la mairie lui a
changé
désormais ils prêchent puisqu'il ne pas
re marier il dit qu'il a redécouvert
dieu ses racines africaines
il parle aussi le justice sociale sa
campagne d'ailleurs la mener dans les
ghettos sinistrés d'une ville dont 70%
la population est noire sur le thème de
sa résurrection personnel et
manifestement il a fait mouche car les
habitants noirs de la capitale fédérale
ont été choqués par l'humiliante
arrestation de berry une justice faite
par les blancs pour les blancs alors les
noires de washington ont voté en bloc le
froid en la rédemption de berre